Israel is continuing to Target Hamas
Terror sites with Precision strikes as
they prepare for a ground invasion of
Gaza time could be of the essence as we
get new reports of hamas's barbaric acts
the Savages are now beheading
babies they're aggressive they're very
bad they cut head of children cut head
of women but we stronger than them you
see the babies the mother the fathers in
their bedrooms in their protection rooms
and how the terrorists kill them it's
not a war it's not a
battlefield it's a massacre it's a
terror act activity Trey Yanks is in
southern Israel Trey uh there are people
that are questioning the accuracy of
this report about beheadings as if the
previous bar barbarism wouldn't have
predicted this activity what kind of
toll is this taking on the soldiers and
The
Rescuers yeah Greg I don't think people
would be questioning those reports if if
they've seen the amount of mutilated
bodies we've seen in southern Israel
thousands of Hamas Fighters it appears
on Saturday morning crossed into this
country and killed everyone they could
find those who didn't die from the
initial attack were dragged back into
Gaza and that's why there are still
dozens held captive beneath the Gaza
Strip the level of brutality just simply
should not be questioned people were
killed in their homes in their beds they
were killed in their their bus stops on
benches this was barbaric and there's
really no other way to describe what
took place in southern Israel and we're
getting more and more information
trickle in that they were not looking
only for men of military age for example
they were killing children they were
killing babies they were killing women
they were dragging grandparents into the
Gaza Strip This is who these Fighters
are and this is the type of Terror that
they looked to in inflict on the
population here in southern Israel Trey
it's Dana
one of the things Dan Hoffman said this
morning was that one of his former CIA
supervisors said the longer you have
hostages out there the longer they're
out there the harder it is to solve and
I'm wondering if you've heard anything
more about any plans ideas possibilities
of getting these hostages safely out of
the Goa
strip he makes a great point the
Israelis and the Americans have no idea
where these hostages are right now and
if you hear anything different it's bad
intelligence because the Gaza Strip has
a network of tunnels that they have no
way to surveil deep deep underground in
places that while the Israelis may have
an idea they are tunneling in certain
parts of the strip they simply can't
identify where these people would have
been taken and with a 25m strip of land
that's anywhere from 3 to 7 m long there
are a lot of places for Hamas and
Islamic Jihad to hide these hostages and
that's not accounting for the high-rise
buildings that there are in Gaza 1.9
million people a heavily populated area
and multiple different population
centers you have Gaza City you have Rafa
in the South and you have hunas in the
middle they could be anywhere and so
even if the Israelis launch this ground
war into Gaza and they take territory
first of all they're going to be engaged
right away by Hamas and Islamic Jihad
militants we've seen it happen in the
past
and secondly they are going to have to
search deep underground to try and find
them which has a whole challenge of its
own do you believe there was a plan in
place contingency operation should they
ever go into Gaza I know they never
wanted to go in but if they have to come
up with a plan as well as mobilizing
300,000 I imagine to be effective and to
be responsible you might have to wait a
little bit I'm not sure time is on their
side do you think they know what they're
going to do and how to do
it absolutely there are contingency
plans in the Israeli military ason for
these types of situations especially
when it comes to a ground operation in
Gaza many times over the past several
years we've seen similar scenes at the
border between Israel and Gaza tanks and
APC staging thousands of soldiers but
not at this level they have trained in
these environments there's actually a
training center in the desert where they
have built similar buildings to what
they have in Gaza City so that the
Israeli soldiers and some Reserve forces
will go to this Center in the desert and
they will work on clearing buildings
they will practice what it's like to
take over a block inside of an urban
battle environment and then hold that
territory and that's exactly what these
these Warriors are going to be doing
when they enter Gaza when that decision
is made it will be a difficult battle
though because of the urban battle
environment they will be faced not only
with small arms fire but RPGs and
unexpected attacks like you've seen
conducted by the Islamic State in the
past hi Trey it's Jessica um I'm curious
we're now on day four um of this
massacre what do you think are the
crucial differences from where we even
were yesterday and what tomorrow is
going to look
like I think the biggest difference is
the shift in momentum on the Northern
front two Israeli soldiers died
overnight from the incursions by
Hezbollah militants there was more
rocket fire from Lebanon not just
targeting the Sheba Farms area this
contested area in the very northern part
of Israel but this time targeting the
Western border between Israel and
Lebanon additionally we saw attempted
morar fire from Syria and we talked
about this yesterday on the program the
possibility of a multi-front conflict
opening up for Israel and already the
Israelis have responded with artillery
strikes in Syria they're looking to send
a clear message that if that front does
open up they're willing to strike
anywhere at any time with all of the
Firepower they have and as we heard
today from the administration the
Americans stand with their Middle East
Ally Israel and they're willing to
provide some level of support for this
fight Trey it's judge Janine you know
with the urban Warfare and you talk
about how difficult uh that kind of
warfare is and they're having to clear
out buildings go into one and then
secure that building and check another a
tunnel uh and then fight possibly this
multi-front War uh it's going to be
extremely difficult for Israel to do
this alone do you think that other
countries will join especially given the
fact that there are American hostages
that we're aware of I believe there are
French and German hostages as well are
these countries going to be asked to
come in and put boots on the ground if
they're not already part of some special
force
it's a really interesting question
because if you had this many American
hostages or killed in another part of
the world there would be consideration
to participate in any sort of activity
to save them and in this case it simply
will involve military
action initially what we are hearing
from analysts in the region has to do
with how the Israelis will fare early on
and so far every indication is they will
do well but it will take time and they
will suffer casualties and so they're
going to enter Gaza they will hold those
buildings in that territory but from
what we've seen in the past reporting in
the Gaza Strip many of these initial
areas that they're going to enter enter
on the eastern and northern part of Gaza
are heavily fortified with militants
we've seen how the Israelis operate in
the West Bank we were embedded with the
Israeli Army just a few weeks ago and
they faced a series of roadside bombs as
they tried to enter the city of tootam
and that's a city that is not as densely
populated filled with militants there
are militants there but not as many as
in Gaza so that's the situation they
face as they look to go into the strip
thank you thanks Trey be safe hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else